uh we loved you in chaplain oh thank you
and it got us thinking about the silent
movie era
juicy uh you know the silent movies with
the the music
the speech cards the comedy custard pies
all of that
and it struck us surely the hardest
thing of all to do in the silent movie
era
would have been to have a talk show okay
it'd be very hard to do wouldn't it
wouldn't it matter
see now yeah you're agreeing yes
so we thought we'd give it a go so uh
we've got a silent movie effect and
music
[Music]
so you understand what's going on yes
you're following us okay so
uh what we're going to do is we're just
we're just going to mine and the speech
card
will do the work for us are you
following this can this technically
be considered now acting with robert
downey jr can we
yes
[Applause]
what degree from kevin bacon are you
then
i can know where i am in the game now
just just don't drop the ball
okay i'm fine
here we go
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
towels
[Applause]
your designer shoes
you know let's help poor man who's just
had a pie tonight
you want to talk about humility it's one
thing to take the pie in the face and
then have them say cut it's another
thing to have hundreds of people here
watching after the fact
[Applause]
right
[Music]
[Applause]
we all have our own little section on
the chair or something no you're
listening to that you're good you're
good there you're
whatever makes you feel comfortable
jedward
[Music]
yeah i was grounded on my lip that's
right did you forget no no it's kind of
weird
smaller and i like fell off a bike and
then i was fine but then it was when i
came up and i hit off the handle
i'm so aware because one time i was
walking around younger and i thought
there's also kind of stones in the
ground and i kind of flip them
[Applause]
okay this big kind of violent okay yeah
it looks like it's just
stop talking about it happy new year so
now
this is uh john and edward's jed word
generally so
nice they're lovely they're lovely boys
what i love but i love it because the
two of you are so sweet and you you went
on the x factor
every week you smiled you did your big
production numbers
and my god and the thing is look they're
boys with high hair
like jumping around having a bit of a
sing and was that your idea i know like
it was kind of weird because i remember
john gotti it's like they only take lots
of skills cut the top but then you just
gotta shave it because the size one in
the top like eight euros and then i just
kept
running and then it makes you really
aired and now i'm trying to get you the
wind like you know you're you know say
like you do lots of running
and your hair's blown everywhere when
you're like oh everyone says about us
but like we didn't intend on doing it
i'm really excited
thank you john rivers
sarah
is this freaking you out about going
home to twins
[Applause]
[Music]
never let matthew see this show quite a
few
uh doctor whovians yeah whovian's
were you two were you two doctor who
fans i mean are
sorry yeah you still are yeah absolutely
i want to get the telly on but you know
it's an institution isn't it yeah from
the days when we hid behind the sofa
like when you go upstairs when you were
a kid did you yeah yeah yeah and
you watched us no i i i was what
our star wars uh they weren't actually
exclusive
well the word because doctor who could
happen
star wars was in the galaxy far far away
it was two sons where there's doctor who
you could
you could get mug to go in the bog so
officially the best doctor who
ever
[Applause]
said it might work for us oh no
doctor who magazine says so yes
and if they don't know yes how often is
that magazine oh
once a month
are you serious how many features
it's packed seriously this comes out 12
times a year
yes why
[Applause]
why would they have to bring that up 12
times a year when people like him are
hiding in your garden
surely he knows everything there is to
know about you already
we'll find out i don't know but you have
started going to the gym and this is
going to be beefing up for the shirts
i mean it's going to be a matter of time
before daniel craig gives over the james
bond role
but yeah i've been uh i've been beefing
up well i would say beefing up i've been
going to the gym trying to stay alive
over the age of 50. i'm very
uncomfortable in the gym though so i
know i try to you know
get i mean you seem like a man he's
probably very comfortable with your body
and happy to walk around
are you one of those nicer walks right
in the gym completely naked
like i prefer the towel on smuggling the
underpants down
the trunk yeah well
no one's seeing what's going on down
here i just i like i was in the gym
and there was a guy and he was wandering
around completely naked weighing himself
pop a towel on how exact have these
measurements got dude
on
guy came up to me and he was he started
a conversation with me completely naked
and he was he just came around the bench
to put my shoes on he just came up like
that
[Applause]
to go all gym crazy with the a team made
you all old
yeah yeah yeah i did but i'm gonna you
do this when you go to the gym
i do the two towel thing where you go
into the shower you have the towel
you wear the towel into the shower then
you have another towel in the shower
you wear it in the shoes get wet yeah no
then i put it over it then i have
another towel
that's how crazy i get about it really
so you're always you're always
embarrassed of what
you're missing i am wait a minute do you
mean you use one as a one of those big
turbans when you come out of the shop
i should that would be a good way to
hide it that'd be a good look i go to
the gym
with my coat on
don't take it off and then a lot of the
time people just try and bounce on me
because they think i'm equipped
[Applause]
[Music]
richard
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
uh
okay
oh
[Applause]
join me next week with my guest
i've include it just 45 minutes
what a weird i just don't like that
no they don't want to play you didn't
get into the business for that
so welcome all to the couch now sarah
sharon
yeah yeah but that's how you say it yeah
because people do get it wrong a lot
yeah like inertia inertia it's the best
way
to i have to introduce myself that way
now seriously like inertia
because people don't have it otherwise
they butter my name but though in
ireland people say a different way so
like isn't there sorcerer yeah i don't
think i actually pronounce my name
the correct way i i say cersei but a lot
of people in ireland say no it's
actually searsha
i think you're saying that wrong so i
don't know
i'm gonna say um john are you hearing
the subtle difference between cersei
i'm just wondering what she says when
they tell her she says her name wrong
not the only unusual name on the couch
because richard on you your middle name
is unexpected i would have thought
something's going to happen now i know
nothing about it but your middle name is
tiffany it's tiffany it is
what's so funny about
it's not the tiffany's by the way no but
it comes through
this was my mother's side that's her
maiden name is tiffany and it came
through belgium somehow
okay i'm guessing you kept that quiet in
school i imagine
you want to know how ridiculous i am i
almost used it as my stage name
no but you're a tiffany dash gear
did an agent just go no no no no
you